i'm sorry man i i do think you you'd be
a fool
to think you've got it in the bag
completely of course we're gonna sit
here and laugh because kamala is like
the worst pick ever no i've said it i've
said it many many times
every single trump supporter is proud
to go vote for him proud no no you're
you're you're wrong
okay well then i'll talk about myself i
am and i can't wait to go but i'm i'm
only i'm only i'm only
giving you a jab the reality is you
didn't give them enough credit
trump supporters will walk over broken
glass to go vote for you
yeah it's beyond proud it is i see you
out there it is like
i am i am not going to back down because
they love this country and they believe
that he is doing the right thing and i
do too
for me it's actually i think more so
there's there's many things trump has
done that that's been really great
economics you you cannot deny it yeah
you know
up until kovid but for me it really is
the democrats embracing of this
psychotic ideology
and them trying to blame trump for kovid
when he literally tried to give them
help and they denied it
and then made it all worse and are just
keeping it worse
they will burn it all to the ground
because they don't like the orange men
yep you see what's going on in new york
now with the uh uh the
the big retail chains are leaving new
york i'm not surprised
this is insane yeah new york's gone to
the to the dogs
all of these big chains like even subway
sandwiches they're like we're out
wow well i don't know how many but
there's no business anymore
i once stood on one corner and i saw
five starbucks
and i was like there's a starbucks
there's one there's one there's one
and i was standing in front of one i
cannot i i'm just
flabbergasted is an understatement when
i see these cities
how they're being driven into the
grounds oh yeah we we've got the the
police chief
who resigned oh yeah in seattle we
actually have that let's talk about her
let's talk about that for sure
what an awesome woman so listen the
context i'm bringing this up in
when i see stories like this seattle
police chief resigns after budget cuts
move comes after city council voted to
cut spending in response to public
pressure to defund the police
this is my understanding is the first
black female police chief of seattle
progress i think so yeah they were gonna
cut her salary
no and not just cut her salary but make
her fire
right a hundred cops that she herself
hired i was gonna say that's not the
reason she's resigning
it was it was a minor cut to her salary
but they said defund the police 100
layoffs
and it was mostly minority officers
this is the insanity we are seeing
across this country from people who
claim to be anti-racist
in california literally repealing civil
rights law
yep it's what's mind-blowing to me is
when i try to explain to my friends
they're like you're gonna make make sure
you know you vote for biden settle for
biden and i was like but the democrats
are repealing civil rights law in
california
and they're like so what or
you know they don't even know what it
means then they they refuse to believe
it
right they refuse to believe it prop
prop 16 would re
repeal prop 209 which says the state
shall not discriminate on the basis of
race sex national origin etc uh in in
public it's public education and uh a
couple other a couple other instances
these are important civil rights laws
that make it illegal
to discriminate on the basis of race and
get rid of it
that to me is an existential threat
to for one the progress we've made in
this country and
that's one of the reasons why i feel
obligated i have no choice
i was talking look i've been talking to
other people of a similar background to
mine and the the argument is basically
when you have democrats saying straight
up we will repeal civil rights law
well then there's literally nothing you
can say to me you literally told me
vote for trump or else and i'm like okay
they the democrats have said to me look
looked me in the eyes and said
your family history the things they've
went through the
the fleeing multiple states because of
these these you know because of how the
system was
was structured those things that
protected you we will take away
and i said so you're telling me i have
no choice but to vote for trump
because if they win you're gonna do
horrifying things to my family yeah
okay thanks i guess i have no choice
what do you want me to say
yeah go ahead no no i was gonna say to
be fair trump has chilled out
yeah and that's and that's been a big
thing because typically when i think
back to the things that really
i didn't like his diction but he hasn't
been doing that no he hasn't that was
you know really early on i would roll my
eyes every day at some silly thing
and i have a sense of humor man i can
laugh about it doesn't mean i got to
vote for it
right today i watched his past couple
press conferences and i was like
he was so reserved yeah today it was
really
i mean actually all of the past couple
months he's been
reserved and when he uh
when the shooting happened outside the
white house
he calmly walked away calmly walks back
in do i look rattled and i'm like
he seems chill impressive yeah man what
am i supposed to say and i hear from my
friends
a friend of mine who is lgbtq said
he's threatening my community and i'm
like
joe biden's the one who's against gay
marriage yeah but he'll give in to
whatever they want that's a good point
kamala harris and biden will do whatever
they're told by the far left
no but i think it's a fair point there
are concerns if you are
pro say trans activism and all this
stuff and identitarian and
ism and stuff and i look at that and i'm
like i can understand why they would be
concerned and upset about that
i literally have nothing else to say i'm
sorry like
the democrats have this insane ideology
that directly threatens
my family and so maybe there's a
dividing one maybe
but i will also say there's a lot of
things i disagree with about the
activism they're pushing forward
the anti-science stuff too well
defunding the police is
a terrible thing we we've talked about
new york
chicago minneapolis seattle portland
where all these places that are dropping
police 129 departments 100
across the nation across the nation
according to a report
this was a report by fox news they said
it was
250 departments were reviewed and just
about half
had reductions in their budgets due to
the defund the police demands
and now we're seeing crime spike
everywhere murder murder is spiking did
you know homicides are
up 250 i think more like 300 in new york
i don't know exactly the number but last
i checked it was ridiculous it's insane
you know the da in chicago i think i
don't see the d.a or the states attorney
i think she states attorney kim foxx is
releasing
35 more she's dismissing 35 more
felonies than the previous
not now now to be the hold on we you
know we really got to be fair
there's probably good reason to suggest
that some of these prosecutors were over
zealous
and prosecuted people they probably
shouldn't have okay i'm i'm totally down
for prison reform and criminal justice
reform
but i gotta say man when when you're
dismissing a higher percentage of
homicides
and you know aggravated assaults and
sexual assaults and stuff like this
at a time when crime is going up i'm
gonna have to give you the side eye and
be like
what are you doing over there more
importantly she released like 800 people
for rioting charges
like low-level misdemeanor stuff during
the riots and now we see mass widespread
looting and i'm going
um i don't know i don't i don't know if
i think she's doing it right
you know so i want to give credit to
carmen best
she is an incredible woman and and i'm
going to read this letter that she wrote
to the government or she went to
um let's see who did she send this to
the president
and lisa herbert of public safety in
seattle so this is this is a letter
directly from her it says dear president
gonzalez chairwoman herbald
and the seattle city council members i
wanted to update you on recent events
particularly those that have occurred
late last night a resident of mine
in sona snohomish county was targeted by
a large group of aggressive protesters
late last night
my neighbors were concerned by such a
large group but they were successful in
ensuring the crowd was not able to
trespass or engage
in other illegal behavior in the area
despite repeated attempts to do so
currently the local sheriff not spd
resources
is monitoring the situation i urge you
both
and the entire council to stand up for
what is right
these actions are these direct actions
against elected officials and especially
civil servants like myself
are out of line with and go against
every democratic
principle that guides our nation before
this devolves into a new way of doing
business
by mob rule here in seattle and across
the nation elected officials like you
must forcefully call
for the end of these tactics she's
calling them out
they didn't though and they didn't and
she's quitting now but do you know do
you know what those local residents did
to ensure no illegal behavior what
you know yeah they came out with rifles
yes they did
and they pointed them at the peaceful
assem assemblers
and they left and they left and and
they're like
we were being peaceful and you pointed a
gun at us and the lady goes that's why
you were being peaceful that's true
my hero so i'm just going to finish
reading because just it sums it up
perfectly the events of this summer were
initiated
in a moment of grief and outrage over
the murder of george floyd by
minneapolis police officers
and so many other black and brown police
suffering at the hands of injustice
all of us must ensure that this
righteous cause is not lost in the
confusion
of so many protesters now engaging in
violence and intimidation
which many are not speaking against
that's a problem
sincerely carmen best chief of police
seattle police department her
resignation is effective september 2nd i
believe
and it is a shame because these are the
kind of cops that we need
carmen best i salute you how ridiculous
to claim to fight for for you know
racial justice
and then target minorities and these
activists are overwhelmingly white
they i've been i was i've been in
portland i've been in seattle
man i tell you this i've never heard
more racial slurs screamed in my life
than when i go down to these events
and do i hear it from the right wingers
no nope of course not it's all from the
left
yep these it's insane i mean there was a
there's a couple famous instances
where these antifa types these black
lives matter people are yelling the
n-word
at cops his name is philip anderson
i've followed this guy still and he is
out there
constantly calling these people out and
he gets
ridiculed and he gets name called so
heavily
it's crazy to watch his videos and he's
just calling him out
like well what about me you know what
about me do i not matter to you guys
and they just they just rip them apart
you know what man i'm gonna say it props
to you phillip
i'm still watching i'm i'm uh i'm really
really mad at the democrats
me too you know why i'm mad why because
they they're forcing me to vote for
trump
they're forcing me to have to do it i
don't i don't like voting against okay
okay and normally unless i hear a bunch
of really strong policies now i'll tell
you i lean towards trump that's why i've
said
you know i'm definitely anything towards
it it's probably it's probably going to
be and it's because of afghanistan
it's because trump wants to withdraw
troops from afghanistan you cannot argue
against that
there listen you can give me a sound
reasonable argument maybe dan crenshaw
has one
but the regular people in this country
who are like i'm either i must be for
the war now
you know oh because joe biden supported
it and trump opposed it therefore i'm
for it
sorry give me a real discussion about
our use of resources otherwise i don't
want to hear it
so i'm looking at trump now and i'm
saying he's not that bad i look at the
democrats and i'm like these people have
lost their minds yep and i've never been
in a position where i really felt like
there was an existential threat to this
country
i've seen elections i've seen the
comments about like you know what man i
get it you guys
i'm staying out of this but now it's to
the point where it's like
businesses are being destroyed they're
arresting people running their
businesses the governor of new jersey
just threatened all the businesses again
and i'm seeing posts from from locals i
know who are like what does this mean
for my business they're going to take
like we're done we're
we're over our company is gone murphy's
crazy yeah these democrats are
psychopaths yes they are bill de blasio
illegally painting black lives matter
without going through the legal channels
taking taxpayer funds and using the nypd
to protect it
and then arguing that the blue lives
matter has no right to paint their own
message and now he's being sued for it
good they've lost their minds i'm not
here to advocate for a message to be
painted on anything i'm here to say
equality under the law for everybody
boom and they don't agree with that they
don't then they need they want
they need to be outed absolutely they
needed to be recalled
years ago and that's why it's like you
know what trump's not that bad
i will absolutely take another four
years of trump and republicans if it
means the crony establishment and the
corrupt
are removed from office trump's awesome
i'm not i'm not
trump is awesome i'm gonna vote for him
i can't wait to vote for him
i know many of you are out there
thinking the same thing i am and you
want to say it and you're not if you're
scared
don't be scared say it i'm going to say
it i'm proud of it i'm going to say this
one more time
if donald trump loses and
you right now are too scared to speak up
out of fear of losing your job or your
friends yelling at you or or making
people angry or whatever
don't be a mean person you know you can
express yourself you can assert yourself
and stand up for yourself
but i worry about how people are going
to feel if they really do think
trump needs to be the person who wins
that biden and kamala are really big
threats
and then they lose because you didn't
want to speak up
i i personally that's that's not for me
i can understand people who don't want
to do it because they're concerned about
their lives and safety and everything
like that but
i do not it would not feel good to you
know if i knew something
was this important and then you lose
you know imagine january 20th comes
around and it's
you know cop kamala and and creepy
sleepy biden
and you could have spoken up early you
could have said something you could have
changed it you could have done it now
this is the time it is it is august 11th
we are less than three months out
speak up for what you believe in and the
same is true for the biden people look
all i'm really saying is stand up for
yourself but to be honest
the left has carte blanche to stand up
and scream
they they break the rules get fired and
then get reinstated like the guy wearing
the black lives matter mask
taco bell's like you're out and he's
like then i quit
there was a there was a venue we were
gonna put on an event all the staff
threatened to quit because
they didn't want some of our speakers
who are gonna be there and that was it
shows show can't go to go go there a lot
of people on the right aren't doing the
same thing
maybe it won't matter because the left
will not be voting for cop come along
because the people in the middle
like me are the ones making a difference
uh most of us are in the middle
most of us see that trump's the way
they're they're over yes let's do it
there have been a lot of polls showing
that independents slightly lean in favor
of
trump and the conservatives and the
republicans i should say all right
but there there is a decent amount of
independents who are leaning left
and i think that's their goal with
kamala they want to try and grab as many
independents as possible it is a smarter
play
but kamala is just a really really awful
awful kid
she's awful yeah she is thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm if you want to
catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode